hello everybody and welcome to port 22
of our practical flash tutorial video
series in this video I'm going to be
talking about my content management
system some of the benefits and
drawbacks to it and all that so let's go
ahead and get started first of all what
am i doing for my content management so
before i well originally Python
programming net was a wordpress
application so it was made with
WordPress which is a PHP plus my sequel
kind of marriage where every single post
that you write is stored in in my sequel
database basically everything is powered
by my sequel database on WordPress and
then like a link actually corresponds
like the Lindt everything is the my
sequel database bottom line and the
problem I had with WordPress and the
reason I wanted to move away is
customization so if you want to
customize WordPress you had to do in a
pre hacky way especially if you wanted
to include any sort of scripts and stuff
like that and then if you wanted to have
like lot like basically scripts our
logic that kind of stuff you just didn't
have the power that you have if you make
your own website so I knew eventually I
wanted to do it because at first I
didn't think I was ever going to do it
but then I started running out of ways
just to organize the amount of tutorials
I had so q-flash so I brought in flask
and then I was like well how should I
actually you do the content management
because you can do it a bunch of ways
one you can you can make an ACP you can
kind of basically write WordPress in
flask I haven't looked but almost
positive there's going to be someone
who's basically done a wordpress version
for flask so you can do something like
that but you could or you could just
have an ACP that generates the pages or
you could do everything static and so
you could just make the HTML page
yourself link to it and so on but even
that was going to be problematic because
for me because I have over you know
probably coming up now on 800 tutorials
so that would be a huge pain
to do 800 hand typed but I wanted to
have the flexibility in the
customization of having actual pages
that corresponded to all the tutorials
that way I could add stuff like if I
wanted to graphs or in some of the
tutorials I've got the embedded console
or in some tutorials
whatever just different stuff or
different organization maybe some stuffs
divided by columns I wanted to be able
to incorporate the bootstrap code and
all that so what I the way I came up
with what I wanted to do is by having
static HTML files so everything's stored
in their template version and the temp
all the templates extend the header page
and they're stored in a directory and
that directory is obviously referenced
by the link in the init dot pi file so
I'll show you guys that I don't have it
up right now but I can bring up the my
example of that maybe later I'll show
you guys exactly what I'm Tarek on the
actual website itself but for now I want
to talk about how are we actually
creating the content because like I just
said like on the one hand I'm saying
I've got these actual static files that
we're editing but how are we doing it
we're actually using Python for it so
this is my method now again I'll just
say that this is a really highly
customized method just simply for myself
I wouldn't necessarily suggest this
method to anyone else but this is
basically me showing the power of flask
because you can write your own back-end
you do anything you want so you should
do exactly what fits what you want what
you want to do so first of all this is
content management this is the content
management not of our application so
this is the content management pie file
for our personal or well our website
that we've been building and so it just
has a little bit of stuff in there not
really much so I just decided to bring
over the content management file let's
just zoom in a little bit from Python
programming on net so let's edit that
one so it's a lot bigger and there's a
little bit of explanation here as well
so this is the the full one content
topic dick so this is the basics topic
dicks then we've got PI game OpenGL key
VC blah blah blah blah blah
a ton
of tutorials right so these are all the
tutorials so this is the content
management app I like I always say this
I'm going to just post it so if for
whatever reason by the time you're
viewing this video if this file is not
findable by you either it will be on
Python program net or I'll put a link to
it in the description it'll be somewhere
findable if it's not post a comment and
I'll put it up so that's the content
management and just let me talk about
that for a moment so currently this is
the organization of this topic dick
right it goes it's a dictionary with the
key of whatever the topic type is so
this is basics followed by the title of
the the actual tutorial in question
followed by the URL and then this right
here is a list of lists so as you can
see this is the basics now we've got the
title link title link title link and
it's a long list of all those and then
we move on to PI game and then we move
on to PI OpenGL and so so we have that
so what's the benefit to doing it this
way first as far as a content management
system is concerned well first of all
instead of ever typing the title of
whatever the tutorial in question is we
actually reference it so we import
content management and instead of typing
the title we actually say the title is
topic dict basics zero zero that's the
title the link to that topic dick basics
zero so that would be topic dict basics
zero
and then the first ahthe um element
within there would be so this would be a
sorry I'm trying to think make sure I
don't screw this up for you guys
so the tight the title will be topic
tech basics zero zero the link will be
topic dick basics zero one so I'll be
the URL so anytime we have a link to say
the next tutorial which I do on on
Python programming at net in the logic
that link is not the actual hard-coded
link it's it's the topic dict basic zero
one okay you'll see that in a minute
I'll show you what I mean by that
because we're actually in the generation
of that is all dynamic as well so if we
ever wanted to actually change a title
we would just edit the title in the
content management pie file done if we
ever wanted to change the URL we would
edit it right here done no other edits
required so that's how we're doing that
and why we're doing that also as you can
see up here in the future I can add
really anything but in my head I'm
thinking well I could probably add tags
so if I ever had like a search bar or
something like that
I could add tags I could also have a
suggestion content so I can have tags
and then also suggested based on the
topic so if you happen to as you're
doing let's say the graphing tutorial in
basics the some suggested tutorials
might be some more advanced graphing
tutorials something like that so you can
continue adding on to this because it's
just a list so if you want to reference
later things in the list you just
reference that index and we'll change
nothing to the rest so that's how I'm
doing the content management so that's
that as the content management file then
we have the HTML Creator file this is
the file that actually creates the HTML
templates based on the links and all of
that so as you can see here cur title
that's a variable and then we've got
some completed percentage stuff but this
is the HTML template that will be
rendered to every HTML file how are we
doing that is we come down to each topic
topic in that topic dict we're just
printing it out but then we're making
the directory we're making each topic
and then we're going through and we're
actually creating that HTML page with
this code and that's basically it we're
writing it to that page and then finally
we've got the init code creator and
that's to actually create the the code
and our init dot pi file because if we
open up in a pie this is the init dot pi
for the actual website let me bring it
over I did I guess I sort of have it up
I've got the back up up so I guess I can
show you guys actually what I'm talking
about anyway this is the end up pie
files
for the basics tutorial so as you can
see that's a lot of code like if you had
to hand type this or even copy and paste
and like edit these little numbers
because you've got these and then you've
got some more numbers it goes on for a
while actually it's a long list of stuff
if you had to edit all those it would
take a long time and then say you wanted
to ever change something that would take
a long time but luckily I have a script
that generates this for us so this is
again this is the actual for Python the
real Python program net so what it's
doing is that then it renders the
template for whatever it is and even the
app root is a variable so remember what
I was saying about if you wanted to
change the URL you just change it in
content management you have to touch it
ever again and you can see again here
that is the case because of a bruit
topic dick basics 21:1 and then the
creation the title of this is kind of
arbitrary I mean it doesn't matter what
the name of your function actually is
but in our case you can't actually have
a variable function name actually you
can you could use lambda I'm not sure
I've never tried using lambda with a
flask but that would be really
interesting actually if you could anyway
I get chills just thinking about it so
you've got basically all this dynamic
code besides the name of the function
but honestly the name of the function is
so you're relevant but I'll show you how
quickly we generate this this init dot
pi code anyways it's basically
instantaneous so it's pretty quick and
then the stuff that we're passing
through we pass through completed
percentages which we'll probably talk
about later that's for the user how much
have they completed then we pass through
the current link the current title of
that page we pass the next link and the
next title so that's for that next
tutorial button so that's what's being
passed there anyway I just really wanted
I just want to show you the what it
looks like but this is the script this
init code creator script this is the
script that will actually create that
init code and you can even see here this
is the function template this is the
template to that code so it creates
something that does at
root and then it does all of these
basically variables that we'll be
talking about later as far as replacing
these variables with the stuff that that
we want so that's the init code creator
and that's it so okay let's see the HTML
creator in action we don't need to zip
it we just want to see in action so
let's go ahead and f5 to run it and we
can see the printed out HTML files here
or at least the file names let's close
this we'll close this and here we have
all the files let's zoom out a little
bit okay so these are all of the font or
the yet these are all the directories
containing the templates so coming over
to our actual yeah we'll just do this
this is the back up of real Python
programming net so coming over here we
go to templates and then you've got all
this stuff and then you go into
tutorials and here we have all of the
tutorials a for a Python program in it
and then you know we can click on any
one of them let's say Django actually
let's do a data manipulation and then
you've got your list of the data
manipulation ones and then we can open
up into individual ones but these ones
actually have true content in them so it
doesn't really matter but you can see
they have the variables as well and the
title is completely variable and then we
come down to the very very bottom where
you have the next tutorial what is the
next tutorial well it's whatever the
next title happens to be whatever the
next link happens to be completed is how
we're measuring progress for users and
that's variable as well and then the
title on the button itself is or the you
know text on the button itself is the
next title whatever that variable
happens to be so that's how that's
created now obviously all this content
this is content I had to hand write
myself right because that's you would
have to do that no matter what your
content management system is unless you
have Python writing paragraphs and
articles for you which would be really
cool anyway maybe with NLT kay one of
these days we'll do that sorry guys
that's how that's working so that's how
we just created all these templates so
now we can go let's let's go ahead and
open up data manipulation
so we were just looking at that just a
moment ago I remember which one we
looked at but we'll look at one of these
and so here is the template the template
is complete
we've got current title we've got I put
this year this is to embed a responsive
YouTube video so I just have that there
just for myself because I always have
that so I wanted that my template here's
the title here's some paragraph tags
written there for me just in case I want
them this is a collapsible basically
like a spoiler I just wanted to always
have have that there for reference and
then here this is a divider so on one
side you could have some code on the
other side you could have an explanation
and all this is bootstrap code so it's
responsive and all that and then finally
the bottom button is there so that's how
it is on every single template for a
tutorial and then I start writing
whatever I need to write or in this case
I most of it was actually moved from
WordPress I actually did that
dynamically but I really don't see any
point to cover that so not going to
really worry about that but for new
tutorials this is exactly what I do make
this and I type right into this page
here and then any time I want to add
buttons or a fancy HTML or custom
anything it's super easy and again it
extends header and all that so anyway
that's the let's go scripts so that's
that that was the HTML creator I'm going
to get rid of it these for now because
they're just in the way so that was the
HTML creator and now how about the init
code creator so again there's all that
let's run it and it literally just spits
out a ton of init dot pi code so you
literally come here and you copy and
paste this code that's all I do
copy paste done and anytime I want to
change anything major that like for
example would change the function let's
say name you can just come in here and
rerun that one time
copy/paste done and so there's that the
only thing I'll just mention here is
when you have a script you can use the
script if you want but whenever you have
a script that's creating function names
you have to be careful you need
to get rid of any dashes you can't have
dashes in function names you can't
obviously have spaces you can't have
commas you can't because basically the
function name was the title I just took
the title so then I have these
replacement functions basically for all
kinds of stuff that cannot be in a
function name brackets periods grammar
symbols and all kinds of fun stuff
anyway that's that so hopefully that was
a decent coverage of the content
management again I'll put these files up
there's you guys can view them and ask
more questions if you happen to have
them I thought about just you know hand
coding all of these and talking about it
as I went through but I think this
content management system one maybe
isn't even the best I want to be
surprised someone could think of
something a little better than what I've
got going on but I think it's a good
illustration of how you can write your
own content management system with flask
and it's super easy and at least I like
it it's pretty quick for me to make
edits or make changes and stuff like
that and I especially like it because I
made it and it makes sense to me right
so if you can make your own modules like
that sometimes it actually it helps so
so that's that anyway um so yeah leave
them below if you've got questions
comments concerns whatever otherwise as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time